in bed
yeah actually catherine said i'm going
to try this because she said that
what kind
uh
about what
oh
well i just
okay let me email him
tell him i just uh sent him oh okay matt
i just sent you that if you want to
embed it
and use the uh
you know use the little uh picture box i
mean the uh
video camera thing
you mean start talking
yeah
okay
well uh matt do you want to uh come and
sit down sorry
okay hi i'm nick gillespie with reason
and raisin tv and i'm joined by matt
welch oh hi nick how you doing why don't
you have a seat i will did you come over
for a cup of sugar
yeah
what are we doing here nick
uh this is our uh live stream telethon
that we are going to be showing
to uh
the world wide web
uh talking about reason uh reasons
annual web-a-thon yeah we are
trying to raise money we're trying to
get 800 new donors to help us uh come
through uh
uh
big in 2013.
uh we first we're nonprofit 501c3 which
means all of your donations are tax
deductible at least for another what
month seems that way so we find out what
happens with the fiscal cliff
negotiations
um
and uh so for the last three years i
think we've been doing these webathons
at the end of the year targeting
specifically our
beloved uh hit-and-run commenters
including
ken spicer who just had baby reason
spicer
a couple of a couple of days ago two
commenters who met on hit and run and so
named their child and i think there was
some kind of auction process too
although that kind of confuses me like a
lot of
uh commenter discussion so anyways we've
had these uh webathons the last three
years getting around 500 donors usually
small donations we have a variety of uh
different prizes and uh
and things that you wouldn't possibly
want like a lunch with nick gillespie at
various giving levels and i think the
top level is 5125
in order to celebrate either missing or
hitting the mayan uh apocalypse that's
right is that how that works yeah all
right so this is our first ever telethon
to do this um during the course of today
uh or for the next two hours we are
going to interview and bring along
various reasons staffers and uh and
special friends um i think ron bailey is
out there we have uh kennedy out there
we have peter suterman and we are taking
your questions uh comments and heckles
um on a variety of places uh you can go
to the uh our twitter feed at reason at
twitter
um or just go to write an email at
telethon
gmail.com and we will uh uh read those
and and mock those as necessary
yeah uh you know one of the uh first
things they'll say is that uh reason as
matt was mentioning is a is published by
the reason foundation which is
headquartered in los angeles it's a
501c3 i believe it's called an
educational and research organization
and your donations are tax-deductible to
the fullest extent of the law
and
this it helps to fray the cost of
producing a magazine that goes out to 50
000 people every month uh including the
entirety of uh the us congress uh and i
can tell you they do read it uh the
other day i was in a movie theater in
arlington and a guy who used to work for
a congresswoman from uh washington state
uh
was sitting next to me and he said hey
are you from reason i you know we got
your magazine all the time and read it
so that's
you know that's the type of stuff we
also are putting out reason.com we uh
overhauled the website the look of it
this year and we're getting about three
million uh users uh
per month
which is a pretty good number of people
and it's going up we're aiming to double
our traffic in a year or two and then
we've got reason tv which launched in
october 2007. we've basically been
putting out about 500 videos a year and
we draw somewhere in the neighborhood of
11 million uh video views a month mostly
through our youtube channel at
youtube.com forward slash reason tv but
that's basically what we're uh what
we're looking for money to help us with
uh reason foundation also runs a uh
non-profit or a rather a research group
a think tank a policy tech uh group
called uh reason you know which is
called reason foundation and they put
out dozens if not hundreds of studies a
year on everything from
uh traffic privatization to uh you know
new ways of getting on with air traffic
control
to outsource things that the government
shouldn't even be involved in and they
work with local governments local and
state governments to try to manage their
affairs better usually by the process of
not managing them at all
this can be trying to help the state of
louisiana
we do a lot of school reform work in
places like los angeles new orleans and
elsewhere so uh money goes towards that
as well a little word here about opinion
magazines um the category that we are in
um
of political opinion magazines reasons
been around since may of 1968 but you
have your weekly standards you have your
national reviews the nation the american
prospect um there isn't an example of
one of these types of magazines that
makes its own money back through
circulation and advertising um doesn't
exist you either have a rich guy who
doesn't mind losing money or a rich
woman who doesn't mind losing money uh
and uh and you you know sell it to a
successive pool of people who want to
get into the vanity publishing thing or
you build a non-profit foundation to
have a floor on it with individual
donors and that model you can either
have someone who has a ton of money who
tells you what to do or you can do the
reason model which is based on
individual donors um and so that's
another reason why we do this every year
um we hopefully add a little bit of
value into people's lives
and so you know we'll take donations at
the 25 level although i think this
webathon starts at 100 doesn't it yeah
although you can give whatever you want
yes uh if you give a hundred dollars
then you uh will also get a wonderful
black reason t-shirt this is an older
one the uh classic distressed it was
distressed the minute that it touched
matt's skin but uh you'll also get a
free subscription to the magazine which
you can either use for yourself or or uh
send to whoever you want uh and again
all of that is tax deductible by a
hundred dollars you can go all the way
up to as you were mentioning something
like 51.25
five thousand dollars gets you a tile at
our spanking new uh headquarters
do we have some twitter uh questions
that we might answer some concerns we
need a copy of today's newspaper because
i believe it was uh episarch
how do you pronounce his name our
beloved comments or episodes uh said um
no it's fist of etiquette wow i'm sorry
uh for both of you um i want you to hold
up today's usa today to confirm that
this is being done live and not on tape
delay oh oh who is that i'm over here
just on cue we have kennedy she's saying
here's a copy of today's dc examiner um
and the date on that is that wednesday
december 5th so this is indeed
yeah thank you that's uh indeed live and
very uh very good so um i will uh scroll
for more do we want to get uh kennedy
yeah uh in a little bit let's uh answer
some questions and then we'll uh
um well there's a great uh suggestion
from hamilton uh for future gifts and
let's just make a note of this is uh two
words
custom monocle giveaways uh hamilton i
think uh your
from your words to uh your lips to god's
ears um i will quickly i need to open up
our facebook page which we're also
inviting people to
comments to
uh filibuster nick here while i'm
getting there uh what about filibuster
oh uh yeah i should filibuster while
we're uh you know uh thinking about all
the questions that we're gonna be
getting but uh do we have other uh uh
one of the things that uh is clear uh
looking forward to 2013 and we know this
uh we've already written about this and
we'll be doing more with it is that if
you uh
consider what we've seen already in
terms of fiscal cliff deliberations the
best case scenario is that uh you know a
deal or let's say a deal gets done it's
going to be between the goal posts that
were put out by barack obama and the
republicans in response neither of these
deals addresses uh anything of real
significance and certainly a real
substance so 2013 is going to shape up
as being just the gigantic year in terms
of uh you know what we need to be saying
if we really believe in limited
government
um
thank you um
i should also point out that last year
during the webathon
we talked a lot about unspecified
soon to take place
improvements to our website and uh the
amount of donations that we got which i
think was just over 500 uh last year
yeah uh really it was i think about 50
000 or 55 000 or 75 000.
around 70. it was a significant chunk of
change this allowed us to undergo a
complete organizational uh overhaul
basically um that is most noticeable
uh with reason 24 7. so we have a news
aggregation site called 24 7
that is visible from every page on the
website or just at the at that url
itself
which has a constant stream of headlines
of things that are happening in the
world and that are of particular
interest to libertarian minded readers i
beseech all of you watching this who are
not familiar with reason 24 7 or not
using that as sort of an open window at
the bottom of your screen or ever
however you people toggle these days um
to look at it it's an incredible source
of outrage and inspiration and
everything else and it was your webathon
donations last year that really made it
possible and in that process we did a
complete overhaul of the website
architecture and everything and made it
a much more uh user-friendly experience
uh there and as a direct result we've
really seen a big increase in traffic
and uh and kind of uh influence and
reach uh over the last five six months
in particular
and now i'm looking forward to have uh
okay
more questions
will there be a cake archduke pants fan
i'm looking at you uh
maybe later
uh
where's
our interaction here okay sorry
uh there was a question from
a stephen elliott asking where the
prospective lunch will be lunch a
thousand bucks get you lunch with uh
either nick or myself do we have anyone
else who's on that chopping block or the
both of them yeah
both of us it's kind of um
it's maybe a punishment or yeah um lunch
can be in washington dc probably will be
in
is a washington d.c
definitely washington dc okay and then
it'll just be negotiated between the the
donor and uh and us um it'll be on us as
well yeah so after you pay that thousand
dollars i mean we'll split the two but
yeah yeah that's fair um
all right uh what else do we have here
nick
um
do you want to talk about upcoming fun
stuff that reason tv is going to be
doing in the new year
any full-length feature documentaries
we're talking about yeah i mean one of
the uh things that we are looking
forward to uh more than anything in uh
2013 is that paul fein and alex manning
have created a feature-length
documentary called america's longest war
uh which is a uh uh
documentary about the the drug war uh
since the early 70s and it is a
fascinating and totally gripping and
just nauseating uh attempt to kind of
tally up the costs of the drug war the
costs in terms first and foremost of
human lives ruined and wasted along the
way but then also the massive amounts of
law enforcement uh
people that are thrown at this thing
which will never be won how it screwed
up our border with mexico and me what
used to be a very uh vibrant and very
peaceful and very uh prosperous area
into a death zone
uh it looks at various people up close
and personal whose lives have just been
destroyed by the drug war where they
were interrupted
their lives were interrupted because
they were either fairly or unfairly
caught up in drug war prohibitions
policies that's going to be hitting the
festival circuit in early 2013 and then
we're hoping to have a theatrical
release later in the year depending on
how things that the festival circuit
plays out but it should be a major
statement in the drug war which is uh
one of the real lights of
rays of light in uh over the past couple
of years i mean there's no question that
in the 21st century uh whether you're
talking about george bush in the
republican congress or barack obama in a
mixed uh
congress this has not been a great uh
century so far for freedom and for the
precision of government but one place
where we see absolute change that is
happening and starting to approach warp
speed really is the drug war the uh
legalization of recreational marijuana
in colorado and washington by ballot
initiative is unprecedented every poll
in the country that's being taken is
showing you know 50 or more people are
in favor of legalized marijuana various
cities are stepping down various states
are stepping down medical marijuana is
now taken uh as a real thing which it
should have been a long time ago the
drug war is entering a
last phase i think and uh hopefully
america's longest war
our great documentary that will be
hitting the festival circuit uh in 2013
will help be one of the final uh kind of
bricks that's pulled out from that just
berlin wall that has
diminished every aspect of american life
since
richard nixon declared a war on drugs in
the early 70s and we're going to be
having coverage of the ongoing fallout
from washington and colorado
going forward mike riggs who we'll be
talking with a little bit later has been
writing a lot about the obama
administration's kind of muffled
response so far
to this although the early indications
that they're going to continue the
current policies which is to make
periodic
uh i.e regular examples out of marijuana
dispensary owners sending people to jail
for 80 years at a time
even in legal states but they're not
going to do they're not going to spend
every single day doing this this is
awkward kind of moment
and it's interesting to know nick and i
have been following this we wrote about
it in our book the declaration of
independence
how a lot of or a growing number of
people uh on the political left in large
part are finally beginning to figure out
how to use the political system
including keeping democrats in arm's
length to try to finally punish the
party that kind of benefits from a a
better vibe on uh on
drug reform even though they don't lift
a finger to do anything and america's
longest worse comes out next year as
part of a
sort of flurry of movies it's the eugene
dreckie movie
that just
the house i live in um there's a couple
of other drugma docs that are coming out
i think you know uh interestingly on the
drug war thing too is that you know this
is something that we pursue at reason
and i think understand more fully
certainly than most conservative and
most liberal political magazines is that
the culture matters and that in the end
really what you're arguing over is you
change the culture and then the politics
follows that as matt and i put in the
declaration of independence which is out
in paperback and is one of the premiums
available for donating to reason but you
know the politics is a lagging indicator
uh and when you see
the absolute you know even obama during
his campaign obama has been as bad of
drug warriors we've had in the white
house and yet even he brought you know
made a bunch of pop jokes including an
ad with one of the actors from
uh kumar uh harold and kumar movies uh
stoner movies made a joke about it the
uh long running series weeds which
ended its run ended with a uh episode
whatever you thought about the series
and all of that it ended with an episode
that took place in the future where
marijuana was legal and that it had
actually been you know pot bars have
been bought up by
starbucks this is the type of stuff
which is not even really parody anymore
it's really this is the near future the
culture has changed and people no longer
can get away with just simply saying oh
you know what pot is evil it leads to
heroin use it leads to uh you know just
people dying in the streets people have
recognized now after 40 plus years of
drug war you know and it's really a
hundred plus years of drug war but that
the costs of trying to stamp out every
last intoxicant especially one as as
minimally invasive and harmful to the
society's marijuana is just not worth
the cost anymore and uh you know it's a
good thing and we're starting to the end
of it i am going to uh bring in kennedy
to uh uh talk so excuse me sure
it's a telethon man
strange new respect for um for jerry
lewis right now
yeah um i'm matt welch this is kennedy
is that your real name that's my real
middle name okay
um uh well welcome uh kennedy she's been
a great stall worked for us for the last
year or so is that right yes doing a lot
of reason tv stuff and reason.com
stuff let's uh can i interview you do
you mind well sure let's turn the table
yes no because i've interviewed you many
times on the radio and also for recent
tv talk previewing uh various issues so
um why did you start hanging out with us
because you guys are i'm listening it's
not that i'm walking away keep going
smart
adept libertarians who happen to also
have
a really great grasp
of culture
and uh being in los angeles where
we don't discuss policy as much as
cultural issues which tend to affect us
more as
a lot of libertarians are involved in
entertainment
and um you know our love for limited
government bleeds into
uh protecting marriage for all and we
too
20.
uh so how long have you sort of
considered yourself at least a soft
libertarian uh or a hard libertarian why
don't i i'm getting firmer by the day
right um it was you know i didn't know
there was such thing as
libertarian but that's what i've always
been because i've held consistently the
same position on most social issues
and um
i find that libertarians are just way
more consistent and interesting and i
guess it was um back at mtv when i
was
investigating my own political
journey and then ultimately had a better
name for what i already felt because i
didn't fit in with a lot of the
republicans and conservatives completely
because uh they despised mtv and they
looked down on those of us who were
embracing culture in the 90s we started
uh uh i think uh first
collaborated if that's the word maybe a
year year and a half ago on john's
fossil show for which she is now
kennedy's now a regular contributor yeah
uh right uh and uh
i don't know if everyone watching this
knows but she's also a morning show host
plug your morning show on awesome 987 fm
you can also if you're not in los
angeles you can listen online commercial
free
at 987 fm.com we have a live stream and
since it is part of the clear channel
family if you have uh the i heart radio
app
where they play great music and then she
puts in little tiny sarcastic and
occasionally libertarian science about
the la city council
and various do you have a douche of the
day too yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty good today it
was uh nadia sulman for accepting the
abn award for her solo porn and and
i was doing talk radio at night when we
first heard that she had given birth to
queen or not controlled octoblets and we
were immediately repulsed by it because
we found out that she was an
irresponsible single mom with six kids
to begin with and we knew that her
children would be on the dole for a
number of reasons and so um my co-host
at the time and i we were really opposed
to any sort of celebration of this
because
it's uh it's bad
news for california which is already
cash-strapped um and in addition to that
uh kennedy is a frequent guest host
fill-in
person on kfi uh los angeles leading
talks what's the what's the tagline for
kfi uh more stimulating we're
stimulating talk radio on kfi
she fills in for john and ken
uh our uh are the mexican guys who uh do
that uh juan he can see
and for other people and uh reason
people are constantly on her show
especially since we started uh
collaborating out together i think i was
on there as recently as saturday yeah
you were on saturday talking about the
fiscal cliff and and right now uh we're
putting together a survival kit for the
fiscal cliff because we're looking
forward it's not enough because you look
around everyone's trying to place blame
for the fiscal cliff crisis we want to
help you out because they're gonna
there's going to be fallout so we are as
we speak creating this survival a fiscal
cliff fall out shelter
uh you said uh as an aside there and i
don't know if you really meant it but uh
that uh there's a lot of libertarians in
hollywood yeah there are who
well it's funny you should say that and
i'm not trying to name drunk but since
you asked me i was at vaughn's the other
day shopping and
when i was at mtv rosie o'donnell was a
vh1 vj and so we worked together and i
said hi to her and
rosie o'donnell she's like are you still
a republican i said no baby i haven't
been involved in for a long time girl
i'm a libertarian she's like i'm a
libertarian and i was like what and and
she said that she had re-registered
she's now an independent and i believe
she said that she bought a firearm or
she was investigating firearms so you
know and you find stories like that a
lot and oftentimes in hollywood the
libertarians come from the left
and uh it's the bill maher libertarians
he's not a libertarian he's not a
libertarian at all he he claimed to be a
libertarian when he first started and
politically incorrect he was a really
interesting show but he's grown uh more
full of himself more addicted to
the red meat devouring
leftists that he just throws a huge uh
donor to barack obama
yeah uh you are in the alt uh rock world
and have been for
a while two decades i didn't say two
decades
okay um there's a couple libertarians
there yeah which which surprised me i'd
heard for a long time that billy joe
armstrong was a libertarian and i'd ask
him but he said
uh which you caused but i guess we can't
talk about that no i interviewed green
day right before the i heart radio music
festival a couple months ago right
before and uh
and then he had this fantastic meltdown
on stage which paled in comparison to
what he did backstage which i'm
contractually bound to not talk about
just youtube oh but it was pretty
awesome and as i've heard he's a
libertarian i recently interviewed
matthew bellamy the lead singer from
muse which is one of the biggest rock
bands in the world and he uh he says
that yes he is a libertarian but he's
also also a trump siege so he loves
knowing chomsky and he's one of the
people who comes from the left and then
billy corgan i interviewed him recently
and uh we had a great conversation we're
hopefully doing something he's agreed to
do a sit down for reason tv
and
he likes being libertarian because he
gets to piss everybody off right which
is really one of the best aspects
because if you go to and this is one of
my favorite things to do if you're at a
dinner party or a child's birthday party
and you know people immediately start
espousing their political beliefs as
though everyone in attendance agrees
with them and i love bursting the
bubbles in the balloons especially if
you have people from opposing viewpoints
because when you can disagree with all
of them
it's magical reminder here we are doing
a webathon telethon for reason magazines
our annual webathon in which we're
asking people to donate what they can at
a variety of giving levels for which you
get swag signed copies of various things
and shirts like this except and you can
also play truth or dare don't be don't
be ashamed to do that number one yes and
number two and and this is something
that what do you mean truth or dare
whatever okay you know that's that's the
nice thing about it do yourself do it
yourself
world the other thing is freedom isn't
free
just remember that
and there's a lot of freedom going on
here at reason as you walk around
and you see uh the various
reason nights plugged into their
computers they're they're editing videos
just know that uh the reason foundation
is a non-profit
organization
uh it's a reason.com donate to look at
all the variety of giving levels um and
uh kennedy thank you very much for
joining us and we have
uh filling up in the next hot seat is
look it's nick lesbi did i mess up the
light i hope so uh
ron bailey
ron
please
thank you guys
uh
yep okay so
uh
i'm nick gillespie uh this is the reason
webathon 2012. we're looking for 800
donors over the next week until next
tuesday to uh to help us uh fund our
fight for free minds at free markets
reason magazine has been around 1960
since 1968 and i'm joined now by ron
bailey our longtime sworn science
correspondent ron has been mapping the
future of technological uh innovation
scientific medical uh bio
medical innovations and as importantly
has been also mapping or charting out
all of the obstacles that are being put
to uh
that our way ron thanks for supporting
me here
what in the uh past year did you find
most uh interesting or hopeful in terms
of just advancing
human well-being and what was like the
big thing that made you worry about all
right well
the most hopeful thing was actually the
supply of energy that's coming out of
steel gas the shale gas revolution is
going to make it possible for the united
states to become more energy independent
a goal that's been going on for since
the first oil crisis in the 70s and this
is moving very close very much in that
direction so i think even the uh
restrictions that the obama
administration are trying to put on it
will not succeed and we'll and that will
be a very hopeful thing shell gas is i
mean it's also we get it through
fracking all right this is true fracking
basically the technology of hydraulic
fracking is making it possible for us to
get cheap available
natural gas here at home and and uh make
us much less dependent on uh countries
that are less
free shall we say um now you know uh ron
is my go-to source for virtually any
question i have about any kind of weird
science that's coming down the pike or
environmental uh kind of uh
controversy yeah i remember you telling
me that it wasn't so long ago that many
of the people uh i guess even the sierra
club but you know people who were
environmentalist groups were in favor of
fracking and shale gas and shell oil
because it was a cheap and clean way to
produce energy more energy and now of
course they're against it what what
happened
well
initially a lot of the environmental
groups thought that natural gas would be
quote the bridge fuel to the future and
the future was going to be renewables of
course the problem is is natural gas is
now so cheap that the prices has gone
down by two-thirds since we had such an
abundance of it that now completely uh
out competes any of the renewable
technologies that the environmental
groups prefer so it's too successful
because it's keeping us hooked on carbon
it's from their point of view it's
keeping a spirit on carbon on the other
hand the fact of the matter is is
because we're now using more natural gas
to produce electricity
our carbon emissions are back to the
levels that they were in the early 1990s
really even though we're
making a lot more energy where we're
using we're using more energy uh you
know i was just reading uh recently ron
was one of the first people to uh talk
about how ethanol when you subjected to
any kind of cost benefit analysis i mean
it it apparently it actually costs more
to produce you know i mean to make then
it gives off and all that but i was just
re and you know this is something that
even al gore has admitted that ethanol
ethanol mandates from corn we're just
like a big bust i was just reading
recently which is kind of interesting
postscript on all of that is that the uh
widespread use of uh ethanol 85 or 85
with 15 ethanol to gasoline has been
destroying cars right around the country
and this is something where if you see
an e85 gas pump that was completely uh
done through
subsidies
for corn producers basically right
basically it is a way of you know
subsidizing corn crop one other thing to
keep in mind is returning food into fuel
the amount of corn that it takes to make
a
a tank of ethanol for an suv
that that corn that the calories of that
corn could feed a person for an entire
year wow um so uh but so you're you're
big in 2012 it was a good year for
energy costs i mean they went down uh
what what were the what was the one
thing that really made you worried about
the future
uh well actually what made me worried is
that in the current issue of the
magazine is the government's ability to
track us with our handy little nifty uh
human tracking devices called the cell
phone yeah and this is the issue uh ron
is talking about it's the january 23
2013 issue which is on sale now it uh
our issues come out a month before the
cover date so this is really the
december issue and it's all about
apocalyptic worries but you have i mean
it's a legitimate one that cell phones
are now of effectively uh global
tracking devices
you know where we're being tracked by
our own cell phones but by by our own
self as the government uh well as it
turns out the police do not and
certainly the fbi did not believe they
need warrants to find out where we are
for example if they can attract us at
any time
and
that is an issue that is going to be
going forward in the courts and we're
hoping the congress will do something
about it but at the moment the police
agencies at both the federal state and
local levels are pushing back against
this they definitely do not want to do
this and they're also trying to keep
citizens from realizing just how
carefully they can be tracked by this
technology well within
something you know what is it like
within six feet or something i mean my
phone on google maps will but if you if
you have a gps phone it can be as good
as within six feet uh in other words
they can track you inside your house
yeah the uh the article is your cell
phone is spying on you how the
surveillance state co-opted personal
technology by ron bailey and it's in the
latest the new issue of reason uh ron uh
let's look at uh 2013 what do you see uh
down you know what what's the biggest
worry that you have about
science or environmental policy you know
that's in the offing and where do you
see something new and exciting uh coming
down the pike
well i'm hoping to spend more time with
some more of the visionary sort of
people i think personalized medicine is
going to take off finally uh as you know
i've been covering the genomics
revolution and all the kinds of
information you can get out of a genetic
code to figure out how to become ill and
perhaps how we can cure ourselves and i
think there's going to be a lot more
progress in that direction are there any
uh case i mean to talk a little bit
about this was it it was either this
year or a year ago that you wrote a
fantastic piece where through the
company 23 and me right uh you know you
uh had your basic genome kind of mapped
or
genotype screening right and then you
talked about okay well here if you have
this
likelihood of getting this you might act
this way or that way right um are there
you know what's what's the uh what's the
upside of knowing that you're more
likely to get alzheimer's if there's
nothing we can do about alzheimer's well
this is the question that a lot of
people ask i say there's cocktail
parties that i took a test so i can find
out how my risk of alzheimer's and
people many of them go what are you
talking about i wouldn't want to know
that and my attitude is well then don't
take the test but don't make it illegal
for the rest of us to have it because
this is always a threat it's always a
threat it's going to be taken away and i
know i was at a i guess we go to a lot
of cocktail parties but with a scientist
who is one of the people who helped
create one of the mechanisms by which
cheap screening could be done
and she said that no way should regular
people have this information because it
might drive them insane it'll drive them
nuts
and that's completely false i mean the
fact of the matter is is that one of the
things you might know might use the
information for is not for medical
treatment so now there are some
treatments that are coming down the
pipeline and if you have certain
particular gene
uh
aspects that's going to increase your
risk of alzheimer's you could now
participate in medical trials it might
help learn but also the fact is that you
may if you realize you're going to come
down with alzheimer's more likely than
not at an earlier age you might say well
maybe i don't want to you know keep my
job here at the federal government and
instead i'll work for i'll go become a
caribbean sailing captain
now they did do a study there was a
study actually published uh a year and a
half ago where they had some people
where they were screening it turned out
that some of them did have uh the api e4
gene which increases substantially risk
of alzheimer's and of course what they
did the people who found that out the
first thing they did was they went out
and bought long-term care insurance
but then the second thing is that they
followed these people further to seek
because there's a stalwart maybe they're
depressed now and it turned out
that a year later they were back to
their baseline they were not they were
not
unduly disturbed right they could in
other words
people can handle the truth oh okay
because i thought you were gonna say
that they're like in the uh national
habit novel uh the fl uh the maltese
falcon there's a bit known as the
flitcraft episode where a woman asked
the uh
sam spade to find her husband who's
disappeared he finds him living in the
next town with a wife he's basically
replicated his earlier life and he said
that he had almost been killed by a
falling safe and he realized he had been
asleep his whole life and that he was
going to go out and do things totally
differently and sam spade just finds him
replicating his existence
so well uh individualized medicine which
will uh you know cut across every aspect
of our lives certainly uh you see that
as coming more and more closer to view
what is the uh you know let me give you
an example of something really exciting
that was just published in the last
couple of weeks is that you know colon
cancer is a big problem the united
states there's now found a version of a
particular gene that turns on
in some people only five maybe ten
percent of people get colon cancer
because of this particular switch
but
what it turns out is taking an aspirin
dramatically dramatically slows down
your uh the growth of that cancer and
you live many many more years and that
is a great finding and it's a very cheap
treatment right so
uh here's a question related to
individualized uh health care and what
not um
when is it going to be possible for uh
insurance companies to use that data
against you because currently now
they're not they don't have access to it
or they're not allowed to anyway
um but you know one would assume that
coming down the road is you know an
insurance companies might be saying
we'll insure you but uh you got to show
us your your genetics first right well
actually uh we have legislation that
forbids them to ask the information
they can't they cannot use it in with
regard to health let's put it this way
in a perfect libertarian world we would
want we would then to be able to we
would indeed want people to do that but
then the other thing that you might be
able to do and there are all kinds of
thinking about this is that you could
purchase before you took your test or
genomic test
uh genomic risk insurance and that could
pay for higher premiums should you
happen to have something that would be
quote a prior risk so so what uh what
what's uh scaring the jesus out of you
and i i want to rush uh ron is an
atheist he does not believe in bejesus
but what's keeping you up at night
uh you know besides uh you know spicy
food
um
i'm particularly worried well how shall
i say and this is not so much the
scientific baileywood but i am afraid
that again the energy problem is going
to be that we're going to end up with so
many regulations that essentially that
the hope that we have for cheaper energy
and safer energy over time is going to
be delayed i actually am a very
optimistic person nothing keeps me up
too much over over overnight i am
pretty sure that humanity is going to
get better over time and we're going to
have some bit of a problem
we're going to have some problems but
they're not insuperable and especially
if we can maintain liberty
well i want to thank ron bailey uh he is
going to uh leave us now and bring in
matt welch with some questions and later
we're going to have peter suterman and a
couple of other reasons staffers ron
thanks for uh working for us and uh uh
you know can you i'll shake your hand
and uh can you uh give us uh
give our viewers a pitch for why they
should donate to reason
i need to go to a lot more conferences
to cover things and that these people
need to send me to them i i go i stay in
milton sixes and that's okay but thank
you we can't even afford my channel six
thank you
okay we're uh going to be joined again
by uh matt welch hello hello uh
reason magazine editor-in-chief
yes hi um nick a reminder we're doing a
webathon telethon reason.com donate
shows you all the different giving
levels and things that you can receive
in response for donating more you can
just put it on my shoulder if you want
to um and uh you can send your questions
at uh what is it again on telethon
reason.com email your questions which
we're going to read you can actually do
it on youtube too the first batch of
questions will come from youtube here a
little lightning round nick yeah sure
and also at our facebook page reason
magazine and even in the comments
section here let's go to a couple
youtube questions uh nick okay
let's see thought telephones usually
advertise some number to call okay
reason.com donate that is uh hi dorp
three um hi door todd welch excellent
last name asks after recent reports that
speaker boehner has removed republican
tea party favorites from leadership
positions which you read about at
reason.com uh for not getting in line
how can republicarians make an impact if
they do get into office nick lesbian
well you know one of the ways is i mean
the people that he's uh removing from uh
you know uh
influential positions such as justin
amash uh who reason magazine among
others have talked about as the next ron
paul i mean justin amash is in his
second term as a congressman he's from
michigan he is a hardcore limited
government character he's a social
conservative personally but more
importantly he doesn't think the
government should be dictating people's
lifestyles uh which is a good thing but
he's been removed but we vote in more
people like that in the senate we vote
in more people like rand paul or mike
lee these are people who we don't
necessarily agree with but if you push
and it's push yeah yeah sorry you know
every there there are no perfect
politicians i'm willing to say there are
some pretty good politicians but you
know that's how you influence yeah and
also recognize that
the strongest influence in politics
comes from without from without of
politics outside of the process as we
were talking about earlier in the drug
war it's not because any politician you
know did something nice that we're on
the verge of beginning the end of
prohibition it's because of the
initiative process specifically and a
lot of citizen
groups that used it and even the medical
marijuana dispensary owner in california
who just sort of bum rushed the show and
said let's talk about legalization we
have a question from lainey frost hi
lainey how you doing out there a long
time you'll see some friends of mine are
interested in intro to libertarian type
books and articles what do y'all
recommend um i'll throw one shout out
there i'm probably not the best to
answer this question uh in general uh
one is radicals for capitalism by our
very own senior editor brian dougherty
it is a magisterial history about the
modern libertarian movement um
it basically has everything it tells you
how uh how things got started it's a big
old book it's a door stopper so if you
want something slimmer that maybe bites
off a smaller chunk i'll tell you one
that had a huge influence on me uh that
i think could use a 21st century update
uh it's by jonathan roush it's not
necessarily about libertarianism but
it's one of the most libertarian books
that i've ever read it was based on a
recent essay from i think 1993
called kindly inquisitors sort of a
defense free speech and
uh and the liberal democratic project i
would uh just say and you know i realize
this sounds like special pleading but
the declaration of independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with america it was written by
matt welch and i in 2011 it came out in
paperback a few months ago with the new
forward uh one of the things that's nice
about it uh and this is what people have
told me and i literally have been
stopped on the street with people saying
you know this explains
what you know what exists beyond
politics and and libertarians talk a lot
about politics as we should but the
whole point is we want to squeeze
politics into as small a part of our
lives so we can get on with the much
more rewarding and interesting and
innovative and fun parts of our lives of
building businesses and new uh
identities and new ways of uh creating
community so the declaration of
independence i have been told by a lot
of people that it really
puts uh you know it uh kind of sells
capitalism with the human face um and
that answers a series of comments and
questions that we have for instance
brett l said wait did you guys write a
book yes we did as a matter of fact
thank you very much still available
thank you kendall
we'll get peter scooterman out here in a
moment let's get to maybe one or two
more questions nick before we go um
there is one from the czech republic
uh czech republic here from killer zelly
that's pretty good man uh why do you
think that there are a lot of serious
topics that people can find out from you
the mainstream media doesn't seem to
care that comes in from our youtube uh
thing you know i mean there's a variety
of theories about that um uh and one
that i would put forth
um and this affects the drug war in a
huge way is that um
there are areas of weird soft consensus
in washington dc especially um of what
is considered normal and not normal to
talk about kind of between the 35 and 35
yard lines right because they go right
yeah um
uh even if at heart people think that
the policies that are agreed on by both
parties are kind of absurd the drug war
is a great thing when uh example of that
when prop 19 was which is the full
legalization of marijuana um initiative
was in california in 2010 which got 46
percent of the vote it lost um it was
amazing to look at the mainstream media
treatment of it which is like what were
they smoking sounds like a reefer
madness again it was all this like it
wasn't even a question of discussing how
there's flaws and the merits of the
initiative it was my god people have had
to marry to bring up something that we
don't really talk about and so we have
to mock and ridicule them in ways that
are just kind of crazy and beyond the
pale
i predicted that and we basically did
not see in this election cycle just two
years later much of that type of
discussion because the nation's moving
we're now 50 or more of americans uh
think that you should meet legalize
marijuana so
the first one out of the gate right the
first one banging the shoulder against
the door is treated like a lunatic um
and there is an incredible amount of
kind of peer pressure in washington in
particular i think of not wanting to
seem like you're aberrational because
you seem a little bit too strange that's
my pet theory no i think so and you know
i think there's also a certain amount of
ignorance isn't the right word but it's
kind of a studied indifference to uh you
know the types of information that
people would be interested in i write a
lot about uh kind of federal budgets and
state spending and things like that and
one of the things that is fascinating is
that you read tons of stories and you
know as we're discussing the fiscal
cliff people will talk about how we need
a four trillion dollar package that will
reduce the deficit over the next decade
etc it is incredibly difficult in major
newspaper coverage to just say hey you
know what the federal government spent x
amount this year they're planning on
spending y amount the year after that
and z amount after that and i think you
see this with things like defense
spending where it's you know it's sound
people will be like oh my god you know
you you want to cut
defense spending in half
uh but you hear a lot of people saying
like oh they're going to be cutting into
the defense budget if sequestration goes
through et cetera it is you know nobody
ever talks about what was defense
spending as a total in dollar amounts
adjusted for inflation in 2000 2005 2010
there's just a real unwillingness on the
part of a lot of reporters to
you know kind of say okay i don't fully
understand what's going on here let's
just walk through it in a very
step-by-step fashion you can have i mean
the reason blog uh where a lot of you
are watching this is in many ways kind
of a daily corrective uh penn jillette
once said to me like every way every day
he wakes up and reads the new york time
on his little device that's the first
thing and he reads reason as kind of a
deep programming of what he just read
it's an ongoing kind of media corrective
or media criticism um because you'll
just have stories about how you know
such and such state has cut services to
the bone it's cut austerity to the bone
or whatever uh engaging you know a favor
uh favorite thing is that you know the
idea that there's a teacher shortage in
america when the number of teachers per
students
k through 12 students is that at an
absolute high yeah everybody knows that
there is like nobody who covers
education but you'll constantly hear
classroom sizes are getting bigger if
you're over the age of 35 or 40 for
god's sake you were in classes that were
twice the size of what the typical
classroom is now and you did just as
well
and in this case the nuns were more
vicious um we'll get some
we will get some more uh of your
comments and questions in the little
bits again this is reason.com donate
that is a suggestion of beseechment
uh and we will now get in peter suderman
i can uh field questions with peter if
you want to go uh i'm just hoping that i
was hoping you want to you want to go
all right peter scooterman come on down
sir and uh i will be back with more
questions
i can get to those and then we'll see
you in about seven minutes matt welch
and you'll uh bring in a new guest
as well
so i'm nick gillespie i am the editor
and chief of reason.com and reason tv
i'm joined now by senior editor peter
editor peter suterman yes uh peter
writes a lot about health care about
budgeting issues and a wide variety of
things also gaming and certain types of
as a movie reviewer for the washington
times uh we are this is part of our
webathon in 2012. we are looking for 800
new donors anything from a dollar on up
to 5100 and 25 cents you get a special
aztec
uh or rather a mine apocalypse package
of reason swag got a reason.com forward
slash donate and you'll get all of the
info on that thank you for listening
thank you for reading and hopefully
thank you for giving we use your money
to underwrite all of our journalism so
peter uh
we are uh in the last couple of weeks of
2012 we're facing the fiscal cliff
uh what how serious is the fiscal cliff
and what's your best uh
reckoning of what's going to happen
between now and january 1st so i'll take
those questions in reverse order the uh
the the second one uh what's going to
happen i think the best bet not maybe a
great bet but the best bet is that
congress and the white house will come
to a deal uh and that we will not um
uh that we will not in fact allow the
expiration of all the bush tax cuts as
well as uh this as well as the sequester
spending cuts to happen the the bca uh
spending caps
was
the the deal that raised the debt limit
right so you've got this big package of
things that makes up the fiscal cliff
all of it's happening right around the
beginning of january my guess is that in
fact it won't happen that there will be
a deal made it will however be a deal
made at the very last minute because the
incentives for both sides
will it be
we're gonna we're gonna take on this
immediately and then we're going to say
in six months we'll come back something
like that i think there's a good chance
that it will be a temporary deal maybe
six months maybe three months maybe a
year or two years but a deal that sort
of buys time
to make hopefully some bigger and better
and more comprehensive deal uh on
spending entitlements taxes and sort of
the the long-term mix that uh that has
been giving us our debt here let's you
know one of the things and this is uh
you know we at reason we don't have a uh
a sin we never write with a single voice
uh but uh so we have a lot of different
opinions although they cohere around you
know certain positions obviously
um what is uh you know you have obama's
original kind of you know
bid in the fiscal cliff negotiations
where he says okay we're going to raise
1.6 trillion dollars in taxes and we're
going to cut 400 billion in entitlements
or some or maybe 600 billion
starting 10 years from now the
republicans came back with what was it
800 billion in revenue increases not
raising rates but cutting
exemptions and we're going to cut
600 or 800 billion dollars maybe in
spending
right so these are the offers that have
been made so far but you have to uh
understand them in context uh as the
initial bids right and what the initial
bids are uh it's they're not actual
plans that are designed to be passed or
even designed to really be uh negotiated
uh in any detail what they are is
designed to
set the tone for where each side in the
debate wants to be seen to be right and
so president obama wants to be seen as
someone who has power has strength has
the upper hand and the republicans and
who is also
dedicated to
you know raising tax rates on upper
income earners and i was just listening
to i guess it was npr this morning or
something and they had a sound bite from
a press conference he gave where he said
make no mistake you know that that is
what he ran on and that's what he's
going to push on and if we don't do that
we won't be able to close budget gaps
even though the amount of money that
would come from those tax rates so
certainly for the next you know for the
rest of his presidency doesn't come
close to addressing anything well it's
funny that uh the obama administration
has been making such a big deal of how
the math just won't work unless you
raise the rates uh they've been making
this big deal since the election but if
you actually go back to uh before the
election over the summer president obama
himself was looking to raise a huge
amount of money basically the same
amount of money not by raising rates but
by closing loopholes in the tax code and
readjusting the tax code just like not
maybe exactly like but very similar to
the way that republicans
have
proposed and so you know obama on the
one hand was saying well we could do
this and now is saying well it's totally
impossible and the math just doesn't
work uh it this isn't about math it's
about politics right this is a not even
this is not even about a plan or about
budgeting right now it's about posturing
uh to sort of set the tone for the
negotiations and position yourself do
you think uh do you think though that
it's also important when we think about
kind of the animal spirits of the stock
markets and stuff you know obviously
neither neither side here and who knows
what the senate democrats are thinking
but you know we're not going to have a
transformational moment here of like
where they're actually going to cut
spending or free spending uh or really
jack up everybody's taxes back to what
clinton was charging or anything but is
it important that they come together
with at least like the framework of a
plan it's not set up where they say okay
you know what yeah we agree we're going
to raise a trillion dollars in revenue
over the next 10 years and we're going
to say we're going to cut a trillion
dollars in revenue or something like
that that for markets it's actually
important to show that a government that
hasn't passed a budget since 2009 uh
that a big you know the senate has not
even produced a budget at least since
2009 is it important that something
happens or going over the cliff is would
it be that bad
uh so i i guess the way i would say this
is that
especially in terms of markets the
fiscal cliff negotiations are important
because they're about a responsive sort
of basic budgetary responsibility and
we're not talking about balancing the
budget we're not talking about even
coming close or anything like that but
as you say we've failed to pass the
budget for the last couple of years and
right now markets are sort of expecting
that these guys will make some sort of a
deal that's that does not produce
radical uh short-term changes that
everyone is saying they want to avoid
and so because everyone says we want to
avoid it and because these changes uh
would be
pretty substantial over the short term
markets are saying okay
we expect that you will then all find
some way to avoid it and do that sort of
fair basic minimum and if they can't do
that that's going to have a big impact
that's going to produce a big shock
because people are going to say wait a
second we can't count on congress even
to do the things that they say they
agree on like avoiding the fiscal cliff
although they do manage to do things
like the national defense
reauthorization act and farm subsidies
so the idea of gridlock is also partly
uh you're the presumed fact of gridlock
is partly
an appeal to selective amnesia uh you
can always count on congress to work
together to spend more money uh well
let's you know you write a lot about uh
medicare and you've been
or rather healthcare and you've been
spearheading for a while now our
coverage of obamacare as well as
medicare medicaid um what is going to
happen i mean 2014 a bunch more of
obamacare mandates kicks in uh what's
happening is you know one of the most
interesting kind of developments is okay
so obamacare you know first off it
passes it passes legislatively where it
looked like it was done but it squeaked
through it goes to the supreme court
squeaks through the supreme court now uh
people are talking about how states are
actually kind of opting out by refusing
to participate in the healthcare
exchange market um you know what's next
for obamacare we've got two uh big
battles that are related one is
compliance at the state level whether
political whether political officials
in states are actually going to agree to
go ahead and do what obamacare asks them
to do because in fact under obamacare
states have a choice whether or not to
implement their own health insurance
exchanges and after the supreme court's
ruling they have a choice whether or not
to expand medicaid the other big battle
is for the states that do go ahead and
do this and for the federal government
that tries to set up fallback exchanges
in non-compliant states is it going to
work and there are big questions about
simply about whether the implementation
is possible technically one of the
biggest is uh is the computer side of it
the i.t set of things right now most of
the states that are setting up exchanges
don't have the it databases these very
complex databases that have to talk to
multiple government databases medicaid
determine your eligibility for exchanges
all these things uh and the that's a
project that most experts think is going
to take about would normally take two to
three years they've got one year to get
it what i mean how you know i've talked
to a couple of people uh some people who
run restaurants and things like that and
they are you know they said when they
look at this stuff and and actually
implementing it um one of the things
that immediately comes to mind is that
these programs were not designed by
people who know like the day-to-day
accounting of of the business which like
most businesses is on a razor thin
margin not of like making millions of
dollars but just staying in business
when you start to look at all of the
implementation things that are necessary
and just don't seem to have been thought
through at all yeah how badly do you
rate obamacare as a kind of [ __ ]
of just like people saying oh that
sounds like a good idea let's put it in
oh that sounds like a good idea i mean
was there any serious thought given to
how this thing was going to work i think
there was a lot of serious thought given
to academic studies written by people
who have never worked in the private
sector
and very little serious thought given to
how private sector actors who were going
to be responsible uh from for obeying uh
a lot of the laws and i mean most most
most business people and i think my
state officials want to you know they
want to follow the law it's not
they're not you know thrown monkey
wrenches in the thing
uh what uh what would be the single best
uh market-based healthcare reform that
might happen you know just if we could
if you could do something tomorrow what
would it be that might happen um
something like the ryan plan uh would be
a good start and by that you mean the
ryan plan uh which would essentially
voucherize medicare turn it into a
premium support program um and that
would introduce some measure of
competition into medicare medicare which
is just hugely distortionary on the
price signals within the healthcare
market and it would also allow the
government to plan more i mean if they
were tough about it they could say you
know this is what we're spending this
year on medicare this is what we're
spending next year it would perhaps
allow them and
it would allow them some opportunity to
do that they're actually trying to do
that through obamacare there's questions
about whether that would work in the
ryan plan or or whether it's going to
work in obamacare but it allows for less
centralized cost control because
basically it puts consumers and insurers
the payers uh the joint payers uh in
charge of figuring out how much they're
gonna pay here's a question for you
you're young so you don't necessarily
have to go to the doctor as much or or
buy as many drugs through the pharmacy
anyway um do you shop around like when
if your doctor says hey this is what i
want to do and then they don't tell you
okay you know well this uh treatment
program and these pills like do you say
hey is there a generic for that uh or do
you i mean do you try and nickel and
dime down the cost of your own health
care consciously so uh the the thing
that i do and the thing that uh that is
common in my family is an awful lot of
online research about uh the procedures
that are being recommended um how
they're supposed to be others how well
they work how they're supposed to be
implemented right that sort of thing
less uh less bargaining on the sort of
specific cost and figuring out okay is
this actually
the best thing what percentage of
patients because you know most people
whether you're we're shopping for cars
or tvs most people don't do that or
restaurants say but like there's a small
portion all you need is like a certain
number of motivated consumers right to
inject that kind of discipline uh right
now even a small number of very
motivated consumers would only make a
minimal impact simply because uh the
price system is so screwed up is so
non-transparent so hard to discern that
hospitals themselves the people who are
sort of responsible for all this stuff
have no idea what it costs in some cases
to provide treatments and treatment
packages they know what they get paid
because of medicare and because of
insurance rates but they don't really
know what it's costing them and cost
tracking within the healthcare system is
so poor uh and so inconsistent that
would be really hard even for a large
group of motivated consumers to make a
big difference kind of
uh peter before uh uh we move on uh tell
me you i mean you review uh movies from
washington what's your favorite movie of
uh 2012 so far uh i really liked killing
them softly which might be described as
the world's only anti-tarp gangster film
um it's uh it's this great clever little
uh gangster just very very cynical very
dry very sort of ugly uh piece about
human nature uh and it's set against the
backdrop of the financial collapse in
2008 and so you're watching uh casinos
being robbed as you're hearing bush say
we have to destroy the economy you know
we have to break capitalism in order to
save it or whatever it was uh and it
makes all these interesting little
metaphors between sort of the gangster
economy the real economy and the way
that gangsters and governments uh either
sort of
run their own systems
kind of reminiscent of the
kind of godfather uh at the end of the
godfather of the original one right now
like k uh diane keaton is saying like oh
come on governments wouldn't do that you
know kill people et cetera and he's like
come on you know our businesses uh what
uh what are you most looking forward to
uh you know a late year release is there
a particular movie you're excited about
i'm uh i'm very much looking forward to
the new quentin tarantino film django
unchanged i'm gonna see it uh this week
yeah before it comes out um it's getting
great reviews so far another fan of the
legacy fan of tarantino yeah are you uh
a 3d is it uh here to stay or i i
certainly hope not i i think that chris
nolan actually has this one right which
is that 3d is terrible and imax is the
real revolution
in filmmaking and that you can get a lot
more out of a picture
just by filming it on 70 millimeter with
one of these gigantic cameras here's
here's a kind of stupid exit type
question but you also are interested in
video games and video games i mean the
franchises and new games will do a
billion dollars worth of business i mean
they're just massive is that the is that
to today's uh kind of cultural
expressive world what movies were in the
1940s what novels were in the 19th
century i mean is it the it medium of
i don't know if i would quite say it
that way investment in a really high
profile gaming is actually going in in
the very biggest budget games is
actually going down and then that
industry is having to figure out where
it's going with itself right now but in
terms of money making and things like
that it seems like it's doing that some
of the biggest hits are doing very well
but it's stagnating a little bit i guess
the thing
that i would say is that it is one of
the most interesting and exciting places
for new for a new kind of storytelling
that is very much uh of a piece with uh
with the internet and with sort of the
way the technology is going because it
allows for participation uh and varied
storytelling modes and sort of stories
that don't have what you know a defined
beginning middle and end in the
traditional way and so allowing
players uh you know users to create
their own experiences and create their
own narratives
kind of choose your own adventure type
of way which is a rudimentary thing you
definitely see some of that but
increasingly you see
games that really allow players to sort
of develop their own stories and
characters uh just to bring this back to
the uh the theme of the day the
apocalypse my favorite actually is one
of my favorite games perhaps my favorite
of all time is fallout 3 which is set in
a post-apocalyptic
radioactive washington dc it's full of
super mutants it basically looks like
coupon circle today all right so that
sounds great peter before you go can you
make a brief pitch uh to our audience of
why uh reason is worth their support uh
reason is awesome for a whole bunch of
reasons uh
one of them is that it is uh perhaps the
best place to find out why policy
doesn't work and what other publications
will do is tell you why policies do work
why ideas are why their ideas you know
sort of will make things uh
for government will make things awesome
but what reason is is really great at is
shedding a little skepticism on uh on an
overly confident uh washington policy
apparatus well thank you very much peter
sanderman
thank you
so we've got some feedback nick okay and
the feedback is that we have to be
closer okay they say that it's basically
been a telephone of a bookshelf
and then some distended uh heads hi i'm
matt welch in chief of reason magazine
we are doing our webathon telethon and
our telethon webathon reason.com
slash backslash
donate
uh every year we ask uh you the people
our friends uh and uh relatives to uh
donate to our nonprofit 501c3 tax
deductible deductible donations that uh
allow us to keep doing this work and
have the likes of peter superman uh shed
important life if you haven't read uh
peter schumerman's profiles of both uh
mitt romney and barack obama and paul
ryan uh go out on our website and and
take a look uh now he's a very incisive
uh young man i think we're going to get
catherine megan ward out here that
sounds great okay do you want you want
to do something a little lighter yeah
let's do lightning round and then we'll
uh bring uh kmw the managing editor of
reason magazine um
the commenter who loves me the most
sarcasmic
asks probably the best uh blog post uh
question so far serious questions can
vegetarians eat animal practice
oh yeah that's a good one
i um just uh don't kick him out of bed
um from youtube um fl exterior cleaning
i presume that's florida ask
how can we end the social security
program when it's already so big and
affects so many people nick and vernon
guruji wrote a great uh piece on uh a
cover story in our august issue i
believe it was called generational
warfare entitlements versus the welfare
state where they go through some of this
to you nick well you know uh it i think
it's a good question because ultimately
social security which is sold
to us now forget about when it started
and how it functioned for the first 30
or 40 years of its life but it's sold to
us now as this sacrosanct covenant with
old people uh retirees seniors who would
be destitute and starving if social
security did not exist uh that simply
isn't true anymore and over the past
couple of uh decades seniors and older
americans have become by far the richest
and wealthiest group in america and i
think you know you need to understand
this or the first thing that we need to
do to get rid of social security is to
you know make it clear that it is no
longer a good deal it is sold as a
retirement package or an
old age insurance that's not how it
functions and its basic uh uh impact now
is to rob younger poorer workers of the
precisely the money that they could be
using to save to make a nest egg for a
house purchase or for their old age to
give it to already wealthy old people
and i think looking at the ways in which
uh you know people who retire after 2010
are going to get less out of social
security than they put in just on a
basic dollar amount if any investment
advisor came to you and said i've got a
great plan for you i'm going to
guarantee you will get less money out of
this than you put in when you're old you
would kick them out of the door so
publicizing that is the first thing and
then recognizing that if we care about
poverty in america we should be giving
less things to most people and focusing
on the actual populations in need and
also that intergenerational transfers of
wealth should
fundamentally they should go from the
old and the wealthy to the young and the
poor not vice versa and start building
that case one of the things that is
awful about social security is that when
the beneficiary dies the benefit
basically dies uh there is no
inheritance to pass on whereas if you
took the same amount of payroll taxes
and put that into a 401k or into you
know a bank account at least when the
person who was spending it died there
would still be a pool of money and even
if it was 5 10 15 25 50 000
that could make the whole difference of
a new generation of a younger generation
of heirs
quickly we have jacob morris i believe
on youtube
what do you two think of anarchism slash
forward slash i guess anarcho capitalism
slash voluntarism um i think they're
awesome um not for me necessarily it's
not how i organize my thoughts and my
approach to life i'm kind of a uh a late
in life uh
recognizer of my own libertarianism i
had fancy names for it um that didn't
include the word libertarianism until
after i started working for reason uh
strangely not um uh
anyways i don't come from a philos
philosophical background uh personally
um but i think without question
the most interesting uh energy happening
right now with libertarianism in america
especially on college campuses and in
things like the free state project
and uh and the whole ron paul movement
a lot of anarchism and and and uh and
voluntarism has been at or near the
heart of it and these kind of
experiments in living are just uh are
fascinating to watch and and it's an
interesting way to kind of interrogate
the state and to uh and to start taking
some basic assumptions and and uh and
unpacking them in ways that are
startling even to people like me like do
we need a state police force why should
why don't we privatize that we've had
conversations with people about that and
it's opened my eyes certainly so not my
thing but i i know i i attract pretty
close with matt on that and i think
anarchy
uh as a concept and as a reality because
it is breaking out all over the place
where people are moving into whether
it's online or elsewhere they're moving
into spaces that are not governed by
rules and they're they're creating their
own systems of kind of uh structure and
uh and law and uh you know as long as
people are free to leave it it's energy
you know it's interesting to be a part
of that and it also really has an impact
on the rest of us should we get uh
catherine manga that sounds good i will
go dig her up okay
so reminder everyone again this is the
webathon telethon for reason magazine
your magazine for free mines and free
markets and of course we're not just a
magazine anymore we are a
full-service website around the clock 24
7. come on in it's okay this is
catherine maggie award everybody and i
mispronounced your last name how do you
pronounce your lesson it's pronounced
men you like mango but you thank you so
you would do an ew with um you know
actually a bunch of romanians have told
me that i say it wrong so whatever i'm
saying it's not right anyway catherine
is the managing editor for reason
magazine let's hold up a copy of this
magazine since it has it's a very good
magazine a nice drawing on it this is
our most recent issue
apocalypse 2013 you might not be able to
read that there but it talks about the
fiscal cliff and about how the
government or your cell phone actually
is spying on you and more catherine is
the one behind the scenes who actually
puts everything together whereas i just
take credit for when it's particularly
good and then blame it on her when it's
bad uh catherine is it repeal day today
it is repeal day and in celebration i
brought a beer to drink i'm going to
crack it open right now and that's going
to wish he had one
is that delicious
son of a [ __ ]
computer sorry about that yeah there's
not going to be a magazine this month
because matt has no computer now sorry
it's repeal day repeal day is an
exciting day uh in the history of the us
of a it's the day that we realized that
we had made a catastrophic
constitutional mistake sorry
and uh and uh re-legalized the booze
here in this country i actually learned
today for the first time
dc did not actually experience repeal
day until sometime in march
as a federal protectorate or whatever
the heck we were and are so
the
so prohibition was repealed prohibition
was repealed nationally uh on on this
day in history but um but dc as a
not a state as a as its own kind of
unique municipal entity um
didn't it didn't actually get its liquor
licenses reissued to bars and retailers
until until march of that year one of
the things that has surprised me the
most about being exposed to all of you
libertarians talking about you out there
not necessarily you but also you um is
uh the extent to which
prohibition never ended or at least it
ended but it was replaced by just a
ridiculous uh patchwork of laws many
which still plague us talk about that we
live in this universe we write about a
lot you write about it a lot we do
there's somehow this idea that like we
have this broad-based national consensus
that wow
prohibiting alcohol prohibiting the sale
and consumption of alcohol in this
country was a stupid stupid idea and
thank god we've moved past that dark era
in our history meanwhile we still
prohibit all kinds of things that are
morally and nutritionally
equivalent
the alcohol um actually breaking news
for for those of our viewers who are in
dc uh dc just legalized sunday sales
so uh blue laws today today they
legalized sunday sales of liquor in the
district of columbia
for anyone who's ever like gone to like
a brunch and wanted to like bring
bottled champagne or like to dinner and
wanted to bring a bottle of wine and
then like oh i'll stop on the way in dc
on sunday not so much
in connecticut there's the blue laws
fight is ongoing and in fact there's a
whole
baptist literal baptism bootleggers
thing there because um the small liquor
stores don't want to have to compete
with the big guys so they like that it's
illegal to sell on sundays so the small
liquor stores support the blue laws
there's also in pennsylvania uh jacob
sullivan has written about this uh
pretty spectacularly
does pennsylvania they're state-owned
liquor stores right right and because
they're state-owned they have all these
civil service rules and so they've it so
no one can like really work there the
hours are very narrow and they have
these elaborate
machines like vending machines they are
the absolute world's worst vending
machines because as you know
libertarians love vending machines we do
because they increase the zone of
freedom they allow for a little bit of
anonymity thank you that's the important
word because you can get weird [ __ ] in
your bathroom um
but these terrible vending machines in
pennsylvania like you have to do like a
thumb print you have to breathe through
a breathalyzer they're just awful so
they lose the state money and no one can
get their booze and it's just incredible
it happens happens everywhere even we're
strongly in favor of uh there are two
kinds of vending machines we've covered
recently
uh caviar in vending machines uh
big uh very popular with the the
brewskis apparently uh but there was
actually some controversy because you
could get some
um embargoed iranian
caviar in some of these vending machines
so that was a little like way to
circumvent the law there uh also um uh
you know of course back in the day
cigarettes but uh there used to be porn
vending machines in the era before the
internet uh the internet is the new
vending machine
editorial stance i think so i mean pro
the
prohibitionist impulse covers more than
just alcohol and pot which we've already
talked about a lot about today we write
constantly about kind of war with food
trucks and and various other things in
sort of michael bloomberg
jihads against uh soda uh and and that
is this all on the rise like is are we
in the middle of a very alarming kind of
trend or is it just we're paying
attention to it more what's what's your
take you know i uh as you know matt i am
all sunshine and roses and so i never
think that we're in the middle of an
alarming trend i always think we're uh
forging bravely onward into the bright
future where everything will be better
so that's where i think we are now uh
food trucks especially there's this uh
sort of fluorescence of delicious foods
that you can eat from a truck
now
uh and despite the best efforts of many
many cities to shut these trucks down
mostly at the behest of brooks and
border restaurants who um you know often
pay extra taxes
or at least have the ear of city
councilman who are making these rules um
even so the food trucks uh survive and
one way that they do it is up in d.c for
example the food trucks until recently
were governed by a rule the same rules
as ice cream trucks right so the ice
cream man comes he plays his little song
but he can only stay at the curb as long
as he has customers and he has to move
on he can't just park and play
thanks to the miracle of social media
the food trucks tweet where they're
gonna be a line of customers is waiting
for them when they arrive they serve all
those customers and then they go on to
the next tweeted location so this is
like a great happy happy example of
technology overcoming stupid laws um
speaking of the kind of uh tweet social
media thing i think also another
breaking uh news today uber was just
legalized in uh dc today tell us
so uh so uber is this is this very cool
company which we've covered extensively
at hit and run and they are basically a
competitor to taxis they are a company
where you can use your smartphone to
hail a black car
it comes right to your door it uses the
gps in your phone they text you and say
that they're outside costs a little more
than a cab but it's sort of a totally
totally outside the often corrupt often
artificially limited taxi commission
controlled supply of transportation they
also often go to neighborhoods where
taxis won't go
um
uber has taken a lot of flack because
they have variable pricing they charge
you more when there's more demand which
happens all the time in all kinds of
other industries but cabs have got this
kind of monopoly and generally it
doesn't happen in that sphere um uber
has been at war with the dc city council
and the dc taxi commission and um
in dc as in many other cities the demand
is so huge and the kind of people who
want it are are activists and so
the state is backing down
i think i saw today uh at the washington
examiner timothy carney who's our the
great kind of anti-corporatist
journalist was mentioning or linking to
someone mentioning that uber and food
trucks
and maybe you know little craft makers
of tchotchkes in brooklyn
are a great way for liberals to learn
that the basic regulatory state that
they otherwise support is really going
to bum them out about the things that
they really care about so one positive
way of looking at oh what is a sometimes
negative situation
is that it kind of reading more hate
but in more productive places right so
uh and i actually did a story about this
years ago about all of the like people
who were like making handmade wooden
toys and selling them at the brooklyn
flea market
realizing that consumer protection
laws are actually can be the death of
their business there's a terrible law
written in response to lead in chinese
toys in 2007 which in 2010 was putting
like
hipster toy makers who embroidered you
know
cthulhu squids on onesies or whatever
out of business
um we don't have enough time to talk
about private space catherine megawatts
probably we put it together like i said
look look nick's doing that kind of
stuff um before nick yells
oh look we got the official okay to talk
about practice here's the important news
about private space super secret moon
mission the golden spike company which
we don't know anything about whoa
tomorrow i've been at that casino in
reno and and then you eat at the golden
corral the whole day is just a wash uh
no the golden flight company about which
we know nothing except for that it is a
group of
um
entrepreneurs
are
tomorrow the rumor has it going to
announce a private manned mission to the
moon
coming soon
to spaceport near you wow you were
breaking you didn't say i was going to
break major spaces you know matt you
should just trust it when i have
something exciting it's gonna be quality
okay catherine mangu ward managing
editor of reason magazine tell the
viewers at home
why they should donate to reason what
value is the world getting from the
likes of reason magazine foundation so
you may have heard on this broadcast
some bad news today but i am here to
tell you that the other thing reason
brings you the other the other
service that reason provides is good
news you read
reason.com you read reason magazine you
are going to get stories about
uh super cool private moon missions
you're going to get stories about how to
follow kimchi tacos on twitter and eat
them and they're going to be delicious
and you are also going to hear some good
exciting news about angry liberals who
are now on our side awesome kmw thank
you very much thank you sir now we're
bringing whoa
we're bringing in someone who's first or
second day or week of work at reason in
2008 uh
when he was an intern he's still an
intern in our hearts i'm not nope uh
he wore a white cutoff tee that like had
you could see you could see side boob
oops
you could see side boob it was a very
unseemly he's now wearing a suit and tie
because he wants to pretend to the world
that this is how he shows up to work
every day mike riggs senior editor how
the hell are you
it was a sonny's barbecue t-shirt and i
worked in the kitchen there and i wore
it because you guys told me i'd be
moving furniture that day
which is what reason interns do
yeah
the first part about being a journalist
just not to lie your face off i am not
i'm not lying okay um
so a reminder what we're doing here this
is the reasons annual webathon and this
is the telethon component which was
going to run until four o'clock so we've
got another 36 minutes of pure
entertainment glory we're talking to
various people from reason and in our
universe about stuff y'all care about um
the telethon is just to remind you to
donate to the webathon reason.com
donate you can see a lot of different
giving levels scroll over the numbers
and it'll say you get to get this
t-shirt or this one you don't get to
wear this tie
you can have lunch uh with nick
gillespie i think you can uh punch him
after a certain level um and uh and up
to even having a little uh
uh
placard of sorts at our new reason la hq
and a bunch of other nice uh gifts this
helps us as a non-profit that does
journalism
continue doing it if you get value out
of us in some way and have a little
extra scratch lying around or you want
to make a bigger deduction from your
taxes while that still is possible uh
then donate some money to us today
reason.com donate thank you very much i
think people also want to donate money
so that they can edit their comments
that has been mentioned has that been
mentioned okay because that's all
they're talking about in the comments um
read your comments you guys mike riggs
is
our uh our
champion of uh of traffic frankly
wow
they don't care about that but mike is
very involved with uh our online efforts
he edits stuff in the back end that
you're not aware of constantly every day
he's looking to make sure that we're on
top of various stories and he's been
covering the living hell out of
the kind of fallout from uh the
legalization of marijuana in colorado
and washington yes and talking to
various people tell us about that i'm
particularly interested people have
heard about obviously the big
legalizations you've been writing very
uh interestingly about the strange uh
responses so far from the obama
administration but tell us about what's
happening in other states or in other
kind of legislative actions that have
been spurred on by this okay so uh i
would say the the four four states to
watch maybe we can say in 2013 would be
indiana michigan
rhode island and maine
so rhode island and maine both have
medical marijuana
rhode island recently decriminalized
both of them are
have legislators who think that they can
not only introduce legalization in their
respective legislatures they also think
they can get republican support so
rhode island and maine could have
legal marijuana
is this been galvanized by washington
and colorado i mean we've talked about
this before they have been talking about
before they've been introducing it
they've introduced it i think one of the
legislators has introduced it three
times already but she said that for the
first time the head of the republican
party uh and this is in maine has said
that he's on board that he'd like to
help head of the republican party in
maine i'm sorry in the legislature in
the legislature in maine
is on board with legalizing marijuana
yeah um indiana held hearings uh and
that's where we got the great story
about the head of the indiana
essentially their highway patrol saying
for up to me and legalized pot uh
indiana is probably not going to
legalize pot that's the that's what the
drug policy alliance thinks
and then the other interesting one to
watch i think is michigan just because
they're doing this i mean you know we
talk about decentralizing a lot of
reason michigan cities are basically
passed a bunch of ballot initiatives
saying we want to decriminalize pot
and grand rapids is the one that was
moving forward the most quickly to
implement these new measures um flint
and detroit uh their city governments
basically said screw you guys we're not
gonna we're gonna ignore the world of
voters we'll just enforce
pot laws under much more draconian state
law instead of the local laws um and so
grand rapids is going ahead except now
there's a lawsuit
challenging this so you know that's
interesting to see i don't i don't know
what it looks like when cities do this i
mean obviously you have ann arbor it's a
great example which decriminalized in
the 70s but um so that could provide a
great model and the most exciting thing
i think about all these states and
cities is that they are all
experimenting with models for how to
reform drug policy because as as much as
we'd all love to see like congress take
this on um
it doesn't look like it's gonna happen
now is is there anything that and i mean
are people talking in washington or
talking more in washington about stuff
like rescheduling the drug from out of
you know more dangerous than opium
category to something a little bit
better is there any movement that worth
talking about yet in washington in the
wake of what happened in no i mean
there's a coalition forming from uh what
congress critters from states with
medical and now states were legal
which is you know 18 states altogether
plus the district of columbia saying
they propose legislation there's some
reason to think that people from states
that don't have
medical marijuana or legal marijuana
will get on board beto o'rourke from
texas interviewed him yesterday he's
probably going to get on board with that
stuff um
but no i don't think i don't think any
of this is going to happen quite the way
we want it to it's going to be basically
i think just uh rebellion at the state
level is what's going to eventually
change which we'll be following
constantly uh we're getting a lot of
throat cutting signs from nick gillespie
here so before we kick mike riggs out uh
i want to uh want to hear from you
telling our readers here what's the
value proposition of reason what are
they getting for their money why should
they donate what are they getting for
their money well um you know i have not
always been able to say this about my
own work but i think at this point right
now you can check hit and run at any
time throughout the day and you will get
the latest most up-to-date news on drug
policy at the state and the federal
level um both commentary and original
reporting and aside from places who
actually get paid explicitly and solely
to change drug policy i don't think
you're going to see that anywhere else
all right mike riggs thank you very much
and nick gillespie
do you want to take my seat shall we
stand up and leave all right we shall
see you on the other end of it yep
you want to take your uh
massive
okay and uh matt you may want to hear
this as well but uh please sit down mr
feeny will do so uh thank you uh matt
welch mike riggs we've got uh now we're
going to be talking with matt feeney who
is one of the editors of 24 7 our
exciting new news feed
function at reason.com after that we're
going to be talking with meredith bragg
who is the managing editor of reason tv
and the uh force behind many of our uh
very finest videos as well as some of
our very worst videos uh and then at 3
45
matt will join me again along with
kennedy uh for some chat chatter and
then uh matt and i will be wrapping it
up and we'll uh you know be uh looking
forward to uh answering some final
questions from you and uh looking at
leather and all sorts of interesting fun
stuff but for now we're going to talk to
matt feeny about 24 7. so matt feeney uh
you started working at reason earlier
this year
um tell us a little bit about where you
were before joining reason for reason i
was working at the american conservative
magazine as part of the institute for
humane studies journalism program and
before that
as the accent might betray i was living
in london working for margaret
thatcher's favorite think tank the
institute of economic affairs that's
right uh so uh well let's talk about 24
7. this is something that was uh a
brainchild actually of drew carey uh as
was reason tv he uh drew carey is on the
board of trustees of reason foundation
the 501c3 nonprofit when you give money
to reason you're giving it to reason
foundation it is fully tax deductible
we're conducting a webathon uh this time
of year to try and gin up some money
that allows us to continue our efforts
to get ideas about free minds and free
markets about libertarianism about
individual responsibility and limited
government out into uh debates over
politics culture and ideas
uh drew had come up with the idea of a
news feed aggregator uh you know where
somebody could go at any time of day or
night and find a bunch of interesting
stories and links that they could go to
immediately from a libertarian
perspective talk a little bit about what
it's like you guys you work four-hour
shifts and you kind of you you know what
kind of sources are you pulling through
what are some of the stories that you
pulled up today and why those stories as
opposed to the infinite number of other
stories so yeah i'm one of a team of
four there's also uh jerry chilly and
scott shackford and ed who are also on
the team uh we pull from all different
sorts of places so we you know hit the
normal
google google alerts and twitter and rss
feeds and what we're really looking for
anything that would be relevant to
libertarianism so the great thing about
it is it's one of the few places you can
go for news on budgetary fiscal foreign
policy issues but also stuff about the
drug war and uh irresponsible government
and uh so i just finished a shift today
and i guess my highlight was it turns
out that uh homeland security were
giving out grants uh for practicing on
uh zombie apocalypse scenarios which is
um taxpayers money well spent yeah yeah
i suspect so
what uh you you write a lot about i mean
you were uh raised both in uh new jersey
the greatest state in the union as well
as england
uh and um you write a lot about uh
europe and about uh you know the
european fiscal uh you know issues there
what is what's happening there is the
euro going to make it or is it is the
euro zone just hitting the skids um so i
think the euro zone will uh well the
euro will be something still this time
next year what exactly it is and who's
using it is still up for debate uh the
the news is obviously increasingly
depressing especially coming from greece
i think everyone
uh will objectively say that greece has
got to default eventually uh
how well this goes down politically in
germany and other western european
nations that have been you know
marginally better behaved we don't know
uh politically and culturally it's going
to have impacts the rise of the far
right in places like greece and even
parts of eastern europe is something
it's worth keeping an eye on but uh no
and obviously this has huge impact for
the united states was the uh was the
eurozone or the common currency was that
a mistake no matter what or was it that
you had a common currency and something
of a central bank but then also some
autonomy but no real coordination what
what's your read of
the why the euro seems to have failed or
to have put in you know one of the
largest if not the largest economic
trading zone in the world you know
totally up for grabs
so there's nothing wrong i suppose in
theory of a country sharing currencies
right but i think the main problem that
you're seeing in europe is that it was
always a political idea not an economic
one and so many of the mistakes we're
seeing is because a lot of the entry of
countries like greece was rushed right
and now it's at the point i mean
objectively it seems like greece should
have defaulted and left ages ago when
this crisis was hit but because it's a
political experiment not an economic one
the you know many of the politicians in
europe are reluctant to do what seems
obvious to me uh and only making the
situation worse
uh so uh going back to 24 7 and you you
can find reason uh 24 7 if you go to
reason.com there's tabs up all over the
website where you can go and just get
that stream whenever you want it uh or
it's a reason.com forward slash 24-7
uh and uh but uh how do you how do you
you know do you get uh you know how do
you pick a story over and over well it's
difficult because actually we're doing
quite good because we've got we aim to
get one story out between every eight
minutes and nine minutes which is
obviously and uh we keep an eye out for
things that are to the reason read the
demographic right uh anything where the
government's screwing someone over or
there's been spectacular breaking news
where you obviously want to get that
covered what i would stress to anyone
watching this is that we take tips if
you guys have a story especially locally
we like good local
police spending uh
stories so if anything from your local
paper anything you can send it to us at
24 underscore seven at reason.com who's
everyone chef will get it and we had to
yeah yeah all right very nice i want to
thank matt feeney for talking uh for
having joined recent staff earlier this
year he's made some great contributions
already and we'll continue to in 2013
your donations at reason.com forward
slash donate will help that but he is uh
one of the uh the uh the beatles one of
the fab four that's putting out 24 7
every day and it's a new news story
every eight minutes this is the place to
go
when you want the absolute most updated
news i mean it's it's interesting places
like the dredge report which kind of
pioneered the aggregation site they
don't change their links very often even
google news and yahoo news don't change
that often 24 7 you know that you're
going to be seeing every time you go
back there every hour on the hour there
will be a huge amount of stories that
have turned over
so thank you matt feeney uh and we're
going to be talking now with meredith
brad
of uh reason
tv fame
is it ready it's about now when everyone
gets upset
yeah okay so meredith bragg is a man man
uh but uh
reason tv uh you're the managing editor
reason tv has been around since 2007 you
joined us when
uh just after the 2008 elections right
and you uh give us uh a quick uh resume
where were you before abc news um in the
dc bureau
washingtonpost.com short stint at c-span
and
been doing other uh
various fun things including traveling
the world and being in real estate
yeah well you have sold uh bought sold
many houses i'm on my third i'm a
recidivist how much um so uh let's talk
about uh reason uh reason tv uh in 2012
what were the you know what what were
the pieces that you think were you know
made the biggest contribution to various
uh debates or discussions yeah i think
definitely our um
uh
the supreme our coverage of the supreme
court um during the health care debates
um and that was in the lead up to
the dis uh to the decision right but
then
you know we had a pretty good inner um
exchange i think uh with randy barnett
we were discussing sort of
looking for some perhaps some silver
linings um which are debatable and you
read the comments sections they
definitely were debated um other things
that we did we was you know gibson
guitar ray story which i think was
pretty interesting
happened in nashville about
earlier last year and anthony fisher
went to nashville and visited
uh the guitar factory and thomas people
there that did well just recently
actually also healthcare related
jim epstein had a pretty great video
about oklahoma doctors and obamacare
right and then kind of the way in which
uh there's a couple of doctors or a
couple of uh uh surgery groups in
oklahoma city that are doing this insane
thing where they basically advertise
their prices
yes and stick to it and have
price wars and all that kind of stuff
it's a fascinating kind of look at what
a free market in healthcare might
actually start looking exactly exactly
um you released a great video today
today's repeal day which celebrates the
end of prohibition alcohol process this
is one of my good ones not one of the
terrible yeah
well we'll get to those because
what's interesting is that almost all of
your total bombs uh you know you
collaborate you know you're only as good
as your weakest link it really happens
to be me
but um you uh you wrote about or you did
a documentary about uh george cassaday
uh tell us who he was and why he met
right so he was the congressional
bootlegger um
and when you say he was the
congressional right i mean
it's during the prohibition for 10 years
from 1920 to 1930 he actually had
offices in the house and then later the
senate office buildings
and he would supply congressman senators
and their staff with uh um
right uh and uh this was people i mean
like who might be like picking up a
bottle from him and then going on the
floor to denounce
absolutely and then uh
he was arrested in 1930 and decided to
give up um bootlegging part of his plea
agreement uh
spent 18 months
in prison though that's in air quotes
because actually uh the prisons were so
full of
that story is that he just went and
signed in and left and signed out at the
end of the day and slept in his own bed
but um he also what makes him sort of
well known and why we know so much about
him now is because he wrote a series of
front page articles from the washington
post
laying out
everything about his operation except
the names
then showcasing just the rank hypocrisy
of a government which was bent on
telling the little people
you know you can't drink and we'll put
you in jail or we'll arrest you while
they were you know boozing it up uh in
the shadow of the capitol right and then
um
these came these stories came out about
a week
before
the midterm elections that saw a huge
shift in 1930 they saw a huge shift in
the definitely in the house and some in
the senate as well of um ostensibly dry
republicans
with wet democrats right
and it's interesting back then too the
democrats were mostly wet because they
were more their power bases were in
urban areas where there were a lot of
catholics and a lot of immigrants and
republicans were more the party of small
town america where there tended to be
more protestants
and who were two tokens right what uh
what else are you working on uh or what
you know between now and the end of the
year layout for our viewers what um you
know what they could expect from uh
reason and and i should point out that
uh meredith is the producer of the remy
videos and very much you know there's
when you think of producers of music you
know you think of people like george
martin with the beatles and you think of
people like rick rubin with various acts
whether it's run dmc or whatever
meredith remy is a is an incredible
talent and meredith is uh one of the
persons you know the person that reason
who helps him incarnate his vision so
we've got a remy video coming up we
actually do actually uh i have a an mp3
in my inbox that i had yet to listen to
so
pretty good good so um uh we'll get that
out um i have a short
doc i'd like to get out about the ai
weiwei exhibit um this is a dissident
chinese artist right and he has his
first
uh the really the largest and the first
real retrospective of his work at the
corporate excuse me at the herschel and
smithsonian museum right now
but he is not allowed to travel to the
united states to see it because the
chinese government
will not release his passport
so it's interesting to have a huge
um
event like this and not be able to show
up right um and having it in washington
adds a little bit of a political change
to it otherwise it's very important
is interesting too because he actually
went to school in new york in the in the
80s
and by deeply of a kind of like punk and
low-rent culture as well as a very
high-end art culture that was booming
there in performance art
so he brings a lot of western
sensibility to chinese art and with the
his the documentary about him is uh
called
never sorry and uh we actually spoke to
the um
to the director of a young woman who
went over there after she graduated
college and basically hung out with him
um in his
in his studio
what makes for uh you know we know what
makes for a good video what makes you
know how
you know is is online video coming of
age
um or is it going to be this endless
proliferation of kind of uh amateur art
form and i'm not that that would be a
bad thing right no i um i
i think
when the um
i mean there's a huge move from
television to the internet and how to
and pushing those two things together
and i think once that happens once it's
extremely easy to look at large
to watch videos on on your television
sort of on a very large scrape format
i think that uh the delineation between
tv and the internet and and
what you may consider amateur
i mean
i don't think in my head or most people
who are producing anymore that
having something on youtube
means that it's not instead i mean i'd
rather have 40 million people watch
something on youtube then 40 000 people
watch something on msnbc right and i
think that that that will continue to
happen
you know for all of us who have younger
young kids or whatever i mean it is you
see that obliteration of these
demarcations that we all took so
seriously that are like you know nobody
gives a [ __ ]
so meredith bragg is the managing editor
of reason tv thank you mayor we're gonna
uh bring in uh kennedy and matt welch
uh to tone it down a little bit right
now but this is the reason magazine
reason.com reason tv webathon 2012.
we're looking for 800
donors uh between now and next tuesday
to help
uh pay for our efforts in bringing you
uh news about free minds and free
markets in 2013.
uh kennedy why don't you sit down why
don't you uh sit down as well and uh you
want to bring an extra chair over
yeah
uh we're gonna talk for a few more
minutes uh and we've got some questions
um and one while matt's getting out
there i have to worry about a potential
donor
uh requested that
mr feeny and i thumb wrestle yeah well
you're gonna have to do that off camera
so
uh kennedy and i realize now i'm off
camera completely but um you are uh a
recovering conservative or recovering
republican yeah talk a little bit about
what happened that uh turned you from uh
you know being a kind of
you know dull and uninteresting
right-winger into a libertarian was
there a particular moment um
yeah i mean it was that that i'm from
this moment that
current loader took me to shay josephine
and gave me a copy of mine ran's
objectives epistemology really and uh
yes
that really happened
kurt got a few glass of wine in them and
thrusters yeah changed bang into my face
and it uh it was a moment that changed
my life yeah
uh curt lotter of course is the former
mtv uh news anchor uh he also reviews
movies for reason and for creator
syndicate
um so and uh he's also somebody i
remember hearing a story
about how he used a story of reason that
was about how organized labor was
basically on the way out and that it
didn't actually help most of its
rank-and-file anymore to help uh fend
off a
unionization effort at mtv
did not know that yeah
um we have a couple of um shout out
requests here that i want to honor
including from scott uwine ewine
sorry i don't know how to pronounce your
name it says greetings from recent donor
and fellow reason cruiser you another
reason cruz you all should go out to
that too
happens roughly every year and we just
uh had ours this summer in alaska um
no it was it was the uh caribbean uh the
time before
it's really fun a bunch of reason curt
loader was in the last to reason crews
speaking of which uh talking about
movies and whatnot um and scott is from
bratislava slovakia as he points out
matt welch's old stomping grounds which
nick always likes to hear a lot more
about um we have uh i just want to shout
out to all the uh commenters um
especially with your anti-british
comments with the matthew feeney
we were reading them out loud
he has an american passport by the way
he's a us passport holder uh yes and i
think we're pretty much done with
questions nick unless you guys got a
couple and here's one from uh and yes
meredith bragg
even his wife uh and daughter believe
that too uh i believe this is from uh
uh calib turberville earlier today
gillespie i was listening to npr or
something
admit it you comment you listen to
government radio i i certainly do i
was not sure that it was npr but
i'm happy to admit that i listen to npr
and i appear on npr from time to time in
pbs
uh and i don't think there's anything
wrong with it
absolutely we have a question from uh
beloved commenter pro libertate uh i
have a question why hasn't the reason
foundation officially adopted the slogan
no [ __ ] you cut spending uh and the
answer to that is obviously if we don't
believe in cursing
uh but that is a uh you know this is the
next step in
the discussion which is that everybody i
think uh everybody with
a brain recognizes we have to cut
spending particularly at the federal
level uh when bill clinton left office
he was uh running up uh federal tax that
were less than two trillion dollars uh
we're now pushing four trillion dollars
uh there has been a sixty percent
increase in federal spending about over
the past 12 years adjusted for inflation
it's clear we're not getting more for
that uh increase of 60 other than larger
and larger deficits so spending has got
to come down and we've really got to
start working on people to stop getting
the vapors every time anybody even says
we just need to freeze spending uh for
instance in a defense spending bill that
was passed recently uh defense people
are going to get 1.7 pay hikes
uh you know across the board as a basic
starting point and it's not the 2.3
million
it's not that you know defense isn't
important and all of that kind of stuff
but it's defense spending has gone up
about 75
over the past 12 years and you just
can't keep doing that especially
was good during the recession
stimulating uh as well that's for sure
uh one thing that we all think about
because uh between the three of us we do
a fair amount of uh tv is that you
always have to come up with a way to
talk about this in 15 seconds or less
which is an ongoing challenge especially
since there's this kind of
default assumption that any
cut in the rate of growth of government
spending is uh is terrifying and it'll
kick graham on the curb and all that
kind of stuff so we're just constantly
looking for ways to point out that if
you took you know everyone says let's
have the bill clinton era of uh level of
taxation and to which we say great let's
have the bill clinton level of spending
which if it had grown at the rate of
population growth and inflation from
2000 we wouldn't have a fiscal cliff we
would have surpluses we'd be talking
about how to spend those and you know
who knows that better than anyone else
yeah that's true um here is a uh a
question that's on point here from adam
kinser given the likelihood of another
failed four years how do you see the 26
election panning out for libertarian
2016 rather uh prosper panning out for
the libertarian prospects
gary johnson has already started sending
out donation emails he said he's going
to take a bit of a breather and uh
you know and you have to create that
infrastructure early so he's gonna win
this time no one's uh talking about him
in the same sentence as hillary clinton
and marco rubio right but what if
hillary clinton became a libertarian
would you vote for him
sure anybody who was willing to cut
spending cut the reach of government in
every aspect of our lives not be
bellicose yeah i mean that'd be great i
don't think that's going to be clinton
probably yeah but uh i'm looking forward
to it i think a thing to always remember
is that
uh you know at this stage in 1989 no one
was talking about bill clinton at this
stage in 2008 no one was talking about
the tea party like politics they were
only talking about bill clinton in
january 92 yeah i mean he was widely
seen as someone who had no chance in
hell so whatever we think about this is
something that nick and i write in our
book which as sarcasmic will tell you uh
we wrote a book called the declaration
of independence uh things in politics on
paperback now right
uh things in politics are much more
fluid precisely because so many
americans are dropping out of politics
or dropping out of political parties and
so they can swarm their enthusiasms to
various ways i think the debt ceiling
and the fiscal cliff negotiations are
going to affect politics in ways that we
can't currently predict uh yeah um as
will uh what i think is probably an
inevitable recession coming up soon well
and certainly nobody in the uh you know
at the start of the 90s would have would
have said okay at the end of this decade
he'd have a pr
uh democratic president a republican
congress that really tamed spending
growth in a way that hadn't been seen in
a very long time and left the budget
at least in a kind of foe uh budget uh
surplus just as you would have never
said in 1971 that you have a democratic
president deregulating stuff yeah yeah
or any president
um kennedy we're going to uh bid goodbye
to you for the weapon in a second but
tell us what you're up to in terms of
your other uh activities
where can people follow you if they want
to uh i'm on twitter
kennedynationfacebook.com
communitynation and you can listen to my
daily morning music show 987fm.com all
right and look for reason videos on uh
reason tv that's right we've got a
couple that'll be coming out uh soon
including one about the jovan belcher
murder uh suicide case uh coming out as
well as a number of other things and
you're also a regular correspondent hour
special correspondent for scottsdale and
fox business that's right yeah well
thank you very much good to see you and
we'll talk to you soon cheers
2012 telethon portion of the webathon
which will run until uh next tuesday
we're looking for 800 new donors uh this
year to uh help us continue to bring you
the best libertarian news commentary and
analysis across our platform reason
magazine reason.com reason tv as well as
the recent public policy group uh that
is part of reason foundation your
donations
of anything from five dollars to five
thousand dollars is fully tax deducted
it's a real lousy time out there for
most opinion magazines most magazines in
general um we have been doing better
than that real lousy a lot of people are
are scrambling around and they're seeing
their circulations plummet and we've
been pretty stable and a little bit up
uh and in web traffic numbers as well a
lot of that is not just because of your
donations and interest in reading the
stuff and and and watching the recent tv
videos and such like but actually uh
communicating with us and sending us
tips and oh my god can you believe that
this happened in missouri emails we get
that about three times a day oh yeah
uh and and everything else it's a real
community that's uh that's built up
around reason and
as much as we like to um read comments
out loud and laugh uh sargonically
and uh and and other things besides with
our commenters we uh value the
interaction very much and uh and it
really makes this whole enterprise and
all of these uh books that were shipped
to us for free and that mannequin in the
corner makes all of that possible and so
thank you for it and uh please if you
find value out of it you got some
scratch lying around go to reason.com
donate
you know one of the things that reason
does which i think is different than a
lot of our peer groups in uh you know
across the ideological spectrum and even
within the free market movement broadly
speaking the libertarian movement is you
know we we take very seriously the idea
of erasing kind of ossified hierarchies
that either never made sense or
certainly don't make sense anymore and
these include uh the hierarchy between
you know content producer and content
consumer
we're doing stuff like this you're not
going to see the nation or national
review or the weekly standard or mother
jones doing webathons where you have
actual access and interaction with the
people
whose stuff that you read every day this
is a part of a huge shift that we've
been charting for decades now and reason
this shift away from the idea you know
that the smart people are up here and
they should be telling the rest of us
down here how to live our lives how to
structure our lives what to think what
to do uh you know we're very much uh
interested in the kind of flattening of
authority uh which isn't to say that
there aren't better and worse ways of
doing things and better and worse ways
of structuring society public policy
your individual lives but the best way
to get to those to that understanding is
to peacefully talk about a lot of stuff
and stop putting on air so uh this
webathon is a direct appeal to you we
have benefited from your feedback as
readers as commenters certainly as
supporters please keep it coming because
we are taking this message out into the
world that needs to hear it a lot more
than the people who are already reading
reason we need to make reason bigger and
better and more visible to more people
every time that matt goes on and dukes
it out with somebody on an npr show or a
pbs show
you know that is that's more people that
we can see uh turning our way turn and
by our way i mean everybody in the
reason universe's way and you know
that's that's where the money goes and
i'm going on there armed with arguments
that i've seen in the comments section
literally people find new ways of
talking about it i think it was more
from commenters than anyone else that
you know it drilled home into my head
stop it with defense spending call it
military spending and then you know
think of defense as what should be a
subset of it there's all kinds of
different framing issues and things that
we've learned from all of y'all and
thank you for it and uh and let's do
what we can
to keep that enterprise going we're both
winning certain things we've talked a
lot about drug policy in the past couple
of hours and you know we're seeing the
benefits of a long slog about uh you
know looking at the horrible effects of
the drug war in america and that's
coming to a close i mean i seriously
think that and i certainly hope so we're
seeing uh increases in school choice in
experimentation uh you know both at the
public and private level people opting
out of school altogether again these are
all good things and then when we look at
the federal and state level and the
local level in many places it's just god
awful reason has been charting ways for
by which the federal government state
governments and local governments can
get out from under crushing unfunded
burdens uh you know that they'll never
be able to pay off and they'll ruin the
rest of our lives trying to make people
you know get a hundred percent on a uh
you know on a a pension deal that never
should have been struck in the first
place we're a place where we can uh you
know we we're winning and we'll continue
to fight for those ideas in 2013. so
matt do you want to uh wrap it up yeah
thank you very much again this is
reason's first
telethon for its third webathon and
we're looking for 800 of you to donate a
little bit of money go to reason.com
donate to have a look thanks for joining
us and for listening to all our great
staff and others talk about what we're
doing here and uh look forward to giving
you another robust year of free minds
and free markets thank you